Speaker 1: So former Democratic Congresswoman
Tulsi Gabbard is getting millions of views for a
new clip in which she spreads incorrect statements
that mirror recent actual Russian propaganda,
I'm not using that term as a pejorative. This
is this is actual Russian propaganda that was
recently spread by Maria Zakharova, as we spoke
about earlier. We talked about this in the
Tucker Carlson segment. This is the hypothesis
about U.S. funded bioweapons labs in Ukraine.
Tulsi Gabbard putting out a video about this has
2.3 million views as of this morning. Let's take a
look at the clip, and you'll recognize some of the
same misstatements from Tulsi that we were getting
on the Putin apologist show. Tucker
Carlson does on Fox News. Take a look.
Speaker 6: Here are the undeniable facts. There
are 25 to 30 U.S. funded bio labs in Ukraine,
according to the U.S. government. These bio labs
are conducting research on dangerous pathogens.
Ukraine is in an active war zone with
widespread bombing, artillery and shelling, and
these facilities, even in the best of
circumstances, could easily be compromised
and release these deadly pathogens like
COVID. These pathogens know no borders. If
they are inadvertently or purposely breached
or compromised, they will quickly spread all
throughout Europe, the United States and the rest
of the world, causing untold suffering and death.
So in order to protect the American people, the
people of Europe, the people around the world,
these labs need to be shut down immediately, and
the pathogens that they hold need to be destroyed.
Speaker 1: Now understand these are not
American. American labs to shut down.
Biden and Harris don't run the laps, and so she
is again running interference for Putin because
that's effectively what this does. By shifting the
conversation into we got to we we have hostilities
going on, and if Ukrainian labs are hit, damaged,
destroyed, it's conceivable that pathogens could
be released. Now that part is true, but it's not
even close to being the story of what's going on
in Ukraine. And of course, the right under the
surface thing about all of this is again, because
when when all you have is a hammer, everything
looks like a nail. The story they really want,
why are they talking about this? They're talking
about this because they want to attack the U.S.,
attack the U.S. rather than just Putin, invaded
Ukraine. That's what we should be talking
about here. Let's listen to a little bit more.
Speaker 6: Instead of trying to cover this up,
the Biden-Harris administration needs to
work with Russia, Ukraine, Naito, the U.N. to
immediately implement a cease fire for
all military action in the vicinity of
these labs until they're secured and
these pathogens are destroyed. Now,
in addition to all this, the U.S. funds
around 300 bio labs around the world
who are engaging in dangerous research, including
gain of function similar to the lab in Wuhan,
where COVID 19 may have originated from.
Speaker 1: So listen, she now is talking about
COVID might might have come from the lab, and
she's doing the same thing Tucker did, which is
the fact. I mean, listen, guys. Labs exist.
Research has done that. Yes. I told you earlier,
there's labs all over the world. There's all
sorts of different labs all over the world
world. There's a consortium called the
Cooperative Threat Reduction Program.
And what they do is they research pathogens.
And when she goes from the problem is Ukraine
to the point is the bio labs around the world.
Why would we shut all of them down, I mean, we
we need to do this research is she's just saying
the research shouldn't be done. There are no U.S.
run bio labs in Ukraine. The country is one of
many former Soviet Union countries and non former
Soviet Union countries that partner with the
Department of Defense as part of this cooperative
threat reduction program. It's public, nothing's
being covered up, nothing's been covered up. The
goal here is do research that would hopefully
be able to prevent biological threats. It's
not to create biological threats. So why would we
shut down every lab everywhere? I just don't get
how do we gain from not studying this stuff?
And that seems to be what she's calling for.
I was reminded. Remember when Mike Pillow said
he wants to sue all machines all in? It's like,
What are you talking about, dude? Tulsi seems
to be saying, Just shut down labs just shut him
down. And so this is typical Russian propaganda.
For years, Russia has claimed that former Soviet
countries are manufacturing biological weapons
in labs funded by the U.S. It's an old Russian
propaganda story. Now, thanks to Tucker Carlson,
thanks to Tulsi Gabbard, they've mixed in.
There's something here related to the invasion,
and it's particularly pernicious or whatever.
These are not secret labs. The details of American
involvement is on U.S. government websites. And
this program, the Biological Threat Reduction
Program, dates all the way back to the 1990s,
and there are no mean. Listen, we if if you want
to argue, there should be no bio research done
well, OK, argue that absent this conflict, then
explain why research shouldn't be done. To me,
it seems incredibly stupid to say we're just we're
not going to research it. Countries are developing
bioweapons. We're not even going to research
bioweapon defense. What, what, why. That doesn't
make any sense. And they continue to make these
unsubstantiated claims and they will continue
because they're 2.3 million views of a video
in which Tulsi has no clue what she's even
talking about. This stuff get clicks, gets
clicks, so they're going to continue doing it